i considered the proposed assault on the
industrial zone in expedient i ordered
it to be cancelled
this is such a case when we must think
about we must always think about this
but especially in this case about the
preservation of the life and health of
our soldiers and officers there is no
need to go into those catacombs and
crawl underground through those
industrial facilities block that
industrial zone so that not a single fly
will be able to fly through
clearly this is a fundamental moment for
that city if it falls completely to
russia it would mark the most
significant victory as it were for
russia though clearly it's it's not much
of a victory given the absolute level of
destruction that's been wrought on that
city and you can only imagine in the
words of one western official to me a
few days ago that as soon and if mario
paul falls to russia is the moment that
the resistance to russia's occupation in
that city starts
um
[Music]
[Music]
the
intercontinental ballistic missile
dubbed satan 2 in the west launched from
the plazetsky cosmodrome in russia's
northwest
landing in kamchatka 6 000 kilometers
away in russia's far east
but it can go much further than that
missile has a range of between 10 and 18
000 kilometers and can carry between 10
and 15 warheads including nuclear ones
that's far enough to reach any of the
us's largest cities probably via the
north or south poles
it's also designed russia says to avoid
detection by missile defense systems
if these missiles were ever used it
would be in the context of a massive
exchange between east and west these are
not missiles that can be used on the
battlefield they can't be used in any
small scale operation they can't do only
a small amount of damage these missiles
are designed to destroy whole societies
if they're ever used russia told the us
about the launch as it's required to do
and the pentagon says that it does not
consider this to be a threat to the
united states but it's quite clear that
by testing this missile out now vladimir
putin is issuing a warning to the west
and showing to his own people quite how
big and powerful he is
[Music]
you